My mom was in and out of the mental hospital
and on pharmaceuticals my entire childhood.
Before she ended her life.
We were on government assistance
and shopped at goodwill when we had enough money.
Childhood traumas had LED to behavioral patterns and lifestyle choices
that were actively working against my physical
and mental health.
I got to a point where my body could no longer handle the toxic burden.
I was forced to flip a 1 80 with my entire diet and lifestyle
to escape the fate the system had designed for us.
I have all my medications.
Stop going to the doctor.
Unplug from the news and conditioning.
Dove down the rabbit hole.
Focused heavily on nutrient dense foods
and their most bioavailable forms
while avoiding as many environmental toxins as I could.
Healed my menstrual cycle
and gained back more energy than I've ever had in my life.
And with that,
I was able to build a business where I get to work whenever I want,
make as much as I want,
and attract the most incredible people and opportunities.